I build a lot of decks, or at least, I start
working on a lot of decks. However, the vast
majority of these die before ever reaching
completion and acquisition. Most of the time I
won’t get very far at all—I’ll spend maybe 20 or
30 minutes digging around and throwing stuff in
a list before identifying something I don’t like
about the deck, usually either that I don’t like
the plan I had in mind, or that the plan I had in
mind isn’t going to be consistently executable.
In this video I want to talk about a different set
of decks, though—the decks that pass that initial
weed-out phase, that seem like promising ideas,
that I spend hours completing a somewhat polished
list for, but which I have also since abandoned,
never to be returned to. To me these are just
drafts clogging up my Archidekt account that I
might look back at as a reference point later,
but I think they can actually serve as an
instructive tool for thinking about what makes a
deck idea that initially seems good actually good,
truly worth constructing and trying to play with.
Because the reality is that a lot of decks don’t
actually deserve to be finished, and being able to
identify when you shouldn’t finish a deck based
on your own preferences will save you precious
time and prevent you from boring yourself
trying to play dead-on-arrival junk piles.
I want to begin with perhaps the most obviously
flawed idea—a Rograkh/Thrasios polymorph deck I
nicknamed “turbostax”. The idea here was pretty
simple—Rograkh is a zero-cost creature in the
command zone, which gives an easy Polymorph
target, and Thrasios is a sweet utility creature
that gets me into two other colors I want to be
in. The eight creatures we’re using our Polymorph
spells to spin into are mostly big, generic bombs
with some sort of nasty way to slow down our
opponents attached—Niv-Mizzet Parun, Hullbreaker
Horror, two different Jin-Gitaxiai—the works. On
top of this, 3 of our 10 creature Polymorph
spells also target artifacts, and we add an
extra artifact Polymorph spell to help us pop out
one of three key artifacts: Nexus of Becoming as
an engine, God-Pharaoh’s Statue as a powerful stax
piece, and Proteus Staff as a repeatable polymorph
effect. To support this dual-type-polymorphing
gameplan, the deck would run a bunch of creature
token generators and even more artifact creature
token generators, which were mostly built into
the deck’s supporting categories like ramp
and removal. The overall goal was for this
deck to be a flexible midrange deck, able to do
cheesy polymorph plays but also able to pivot
into grindier gameplans and crunch value into the
late game with Thrasios. And, that flexibility was
precisely what I found appealing about the deck.
Like other cheese strategies such as reanimator,
Polymorph can feel a little all-or-nothing: either
you land the big idiot and do some nasty stuff
with it, or you fall flat. However, this design
of free-Polymorph-target-plus-value-engine in the
command zone, along with all the baked in utility,
could mean much better resilience. The deck also
had a lot of land ramp sorceries, since that’s
what was required for its creature-and-artifact
polymorph gameplan, and that sort of ramp base
along with Thrasios already makes for a difficult
to stop engine. Finally, the three commander storm
cards all let this deck come surging back into the
game even after it’s been shut down, and the idea
of Echo Storming to create 5 copies of Nexus of
Becoming is extremely tasty. So, what was this
deck’s problem? Why didn’t I end up building it?
The biggest issue was that the deck was simply too
generic, and generically mean at that. Thrasios
plus ramp is a very generic gameplan. All of my
top end creatures were generic disgusting bombs,
with four being played in at least 7% of
in-color decks, and another three being
infamously oppressive Praetors. The gameplan
had essentially zero synergistic core to it,
because a polymorph deck with that many targets
can’t really have a synergistic core to it,
the cards it finds can’t be anything but
generic soul-crushing bombs. Polymorphing is
a cool mechanism to arrive at those bombs,
but that doesn’t make them interesting,
either for me or for my opponents. So, the deck
got scrapped, never to be returned to. That said,
with each of these three decks I think it’s worth
asking—was there any of what excited me about the
original idea that could turn into an interesting
deck? Well, Rograkh polymorph does seem like a
workable core as an easy way to grab from a
selection of creatures while still having access
to a second commander, but I’d want it to be
something more specific than Thrasios. If I were
to take another crack at this idea it’d need to be
with a partner like Kydele or Sakashima that has
a bit more specificity, and then the things to be
polymorphed for would need to be far less generic.
The tricky thing here would be finding enough
different options that the deck would always be
happy with—with fewer than three polymorph targets
the deck would be in total gimmick territory,
while with too many the deck would probably end
up with a generic and boring gameplan once again,
or alternatively a wildly inconsistent one.
Finding several different high-cost cards
that generally fill the same specific
niche within the deck is a tricky task,
but that’s the only way I’d want to touch
polymorph again as a primary feature of a deck.
If you’re enjoying this video you should
hit all the buttons you see on your screen,
each and every one of them. You can also sign up
for my Patreon or a YouTube membership if you want
to support what I do here, and you’ll also get
access to a companion piece to this video where I
talk about three more decks I haven’t given up on.
A preview of that will be at the end of the video.
The next deck I didn’t finish is
one that I nicknamed Goblin Throne,
and this one was far more recent. This is a
deck built around Throne of the Grim Captain,
a two mana artifact whose front side taps to mill
two cards and which can exile a Dinosaur, Merfolk,
Pirate, and Vampire from your board or graveyard
to flip. The backside is a 7/7 creature with
a bunch of keywords that also has an on-attack
trigger, forcing opponents to sacrifice a nonland
permanent and putting one of the typed-creatures
exiled with it into play tapped and attacking.
This is a fairly attractive hidden commander
to me for a bunch of reasons: the colors are
relatively flexible, the creature types it
uses feature a variety of interesting designs,
the card’s attributes make it findable with
a number of different conditional tutors,
and the front side of it is just a decently-costed
graveyard enabler in its own right. When I was
first deciding what I should do with this card,
I decided that Grixis was the easiest color
identity to work with, since Blue was the primary
color for Merfolk, and red was a great secondary
color for the other three types that also gave
better access haste. Then, I decided I wanted a
commander that was graveyard-based in some form
or other, sharing either a graveyard setup or a
graveyard payoff with Throne. I’m also a sucker
for a low-cost commander, so naturally I stumbled
onto Norman Osborn, a looter guy on the two mana
side and a powerful discard payoff on the four
mana side. This is a reasonably popular commander,
but the pairing with Throne of the Grim Captain
is relatively less common. There’s a lot to work
with here, though: Surly Badgersaur and Flaming
Tyrannosaurus as madness-friendly dinos, all sorts
of looting pirates, multiple graveyard-friendly
merfolk, and basically the entire vampire
subtype. We’ve also got the Incarnations to give
our stuff keywords when they’re in the graveyard,
a couple beautifully fitting extra combat cards
to let us Grim Captain even harder, and various
other unique cards that slot nicely into some
role or other. All sorts of cards I find cool and
exciting managed to find their way into this deck:
Strefan, Kiora the Rising Tide, Captain Howler,
Forbid, and Necrogoyf. So, what went wrong?
On the surface, everything looks fine. Unlike the
last deck, this one decidedly does have synergies,
its creatures do feel more intentionally chosen,
and its gameplan does seem more unique. Still,
my impression of the deck after thinking about it
longer is that it is simply less than the sum of
its parts, and the sheer power of its commander is
part of the issue here. I successfully identified
that a discard subtheme within these colors and
with these creature types was going to work well,
but my commander actually makes that too easy.
Whereas other discard-oriented decks I play use
unique payoffs like Sharuum or Ox of Agonas that
want to be in a pretty specific type of deck,
Green Goblin simply lets me cast anything I
discarded that turn with a two-mana discount,
turning my cool discard plan into a torrent
of generic Magic: the Gathering gameplay.
Now, this might make it seem like the
issue primarily lies with the commander,
but really that’s not quite true. Using a
powerful, somewhat more generic discard commander
like Norman Osborn to support a more specific
and textured gameplan could be a cool idea,
but Throne of the Grim Captain just isn’t that
cool as a thing to center a deck around. The card
itself is a graveyard enabler and a fun payoff
that can be a fairly significant singular threat,
but it’s not really well-situated to anchor a
gameplan. Likewise, the sorts of deck construction
it encourages, with a split of the four different
creature types, is kind of fun to build, but
doesn’t actually create a coherent gameplan to be
amplified. It’s “the Volo problem”—a card creating
constraints that are fun to deckbuild around but
which don’t actually create interesting gameplay
on their own. While this deck’s non-throne,
non-Goblin cards have some graveyard and discard
themes that kinda work with one another, it was a
relatively generic midrangy affair on the whole,
without enough of an identity to feel like
a coherent deck. So, I scrapped the idea.
To be clear, I’m not against building a Throne
of the Grim Captain deck in the future—the card
still slaps even if I didn’t like this usage
of it. However, I think it’d essentially need
to be a mostly-formed deck where the card
just happened to make sense, a deck where
Throne could add spice to a strong existing
identity rather than being expected to create
identity all on its own. I actually did a little
experiment while writing this video where I tried
to slap together a different Throne of the Grim
Captain deck that solves the issues I have with
the card in this deck. I went Mardu colors instead
of Grixis, with Kroxa and Kunoros in the command
zone instead of Norman Osborn. It was sort of
a graveyard cheese reanimator type situation,
with all manner of spicy high cost dinosaurs and
vampires alongside a bunch of graveyard enablers
and enough of the other types to get by. This deck
had a distinct identity with its different types,
a punchy aggressive playstyle, and a bunch
of congruence between the command zone and
Throne of the Grim Captain. The two can work
alongside each other, but they’re also rough
analogs which is nice for if Throne gets
removed or if I’m struggling to keep the
graveyard stocked for K&K. So, every issue I
have with Goblin Throne is basically solved
with this cool reanimator deck. It’s also not the
sort of deck I’m really interested in playing,
kinda fragile and not wildly flexible in
its play paths. Just not my cup of tea.
This is the challenge of deckbuilding: there
are multiple elements that need to line up
in order to make a deck I’m building worth
finishing, and sometimes solving one set of
issues I have with a deck just leads to an
entirely different set of issues. Learning
to identify those issues early in the process and
hold back on finishing a deck is a helpful thing.
This channel is sponsored by Dragonshield,
and if you haven’t already you should
check out their beautiful new line of
Guild Sleeves. These are dual-matte,
so one side is the guild-design and the other side
is a solid color that provides a great backing
for your cards. Follow my link in the description
and use code “salubrious” at checkout for 5% off.
The final deck I didn’t build is one I refer to
as “Enigmatic Control”, and this is the one I’ve
spent by far the most time thinking about.
The pivotal card of this deck was Enigmatic
Incarnation, a four mana enchantment in Simic
colors that allows its controller to sacrifice
an enchantment on their end step, searching up
a creature with mana value one greater to put
into play. Immediately, this is appealing as an
unconventional birthing pod effect. Enchantment
creatures are one obvious application here,
since an enchantment creature can be sacrificed
to find a different enchantment creature just
like a normal pod effect, but there are other
interesting options as well. Enchantments with
ETBs make for nice sacrifice targets, as do Sagas
which have quite a few different options. There
are also a number of non-enchantment creatures
to be grabbed that have great synergy with an
enchantment sacrificing gameplan, such as Tameshi,
Harnessed Snubhorn, and Moon-blessed Cleric. This
deck was looking to assemble a solid toolbox-y
sort of game plan with some of these different
options, although there was a final challenge of
when Enigmatic Incarnation triggered: on the end
step. This is a little bit of a problem for us,
because it means we can’t get immediate use out
of any creatures we grab in the way we could with
a conventional pod effect. No grabbing a card
draw creature to hit a land drop, no grabbing a
removal creature to enable a good attack step, no
grabbing a synergy piece creature to set up some
sweet spells, and so forth. To me, this meant two
things: for one, flash enablers were going to be
a notable part of our gameplan so that we can
play more on our opponents turns, and for two,
this deck’s general plan needed to be a bit slower
and more controlling. These two features combined
with an enchantment-centered gameplan also made
a particular type of card very useful: rule of
law effects. Preventing each player from casting
more than one spell each turn can do wonders for
keeping people in check, especially in a deck that
has counterspells to stop even that one spell if
it’s a bit too spooky. Realistically this means
that we need white in our color identity, so it
was at this point where I picked out a relatively
generic enchantment commander: Tuvasa the Sunlit.
Tuvasa’s draw is nice for taking a bit of strain
off of our value engines, and the fact that Tuvasa
herself gets decently big with enough enchantments
on board also allows her to be a wincon for us.
This feature of the card is compounded by a
few evasion enchantments like Unquestioned
Authority and Thassa God of the Sea, and the
fact that these can simply be sacrificed to
find something else if the commander beatdown
plan doesn’t seem doable is a nice bit of
flexibility. Aside from commander beatdown, this
deck had a handful of other options for winning,
most of them a little grittier. The deck featured
Karametra as a god that can give a ton of ramp,
and then there are some different options for
turning this mana advantage into a lock of sorts.
The deck had several different enchantress
effects, and these could be paired with Words
of Wind to repeatedly bounce a ramp enchantment
stripping away resources from our opponents. The
deck also had Fear of Sleep Paralysis in it, which
could lock down opposing creatures if we were
playing enough enchantments. Both of these are
tricky to pull off with a rule of law effect still
in play unless we have Heliod the Warped Eclipse
in play, but luckily for us our deck is built
around sacrificing enchantments, so we have the
ability to get the rule of law enchantments out
of there whenever we’re ready. Once we’re heavily
taxing our opponents ability to play the game,
the idea was to beat them down with an army
of enchantment creatures and/or our commander.
So, why didn’t I finish up and buy this deck?
Well, there were some pretty fundamental issues,
mostly all stemming from the fact that Enigmatic
Incarnation is not a very good card. It’s slow as
a primary engine since it’s 4 mana and triggers
on end step, and though it synergizes well with
the Duskmourn Overlords, there are only
three of those available in the colors.
Maybe there could be a version of this deck
where we dip into the 7 other enchantments in
the game that can get heavily discounted
by certain requirements being fulfilled,
but these cards tend to be highly varied and not
necessarily conducive to a focused gameplan. Now,
trying to pump up the strength of a cool but
mediocre card is not necessarily a bad time,
and that is precisely what this deck
was trying to do. To accomplish this,
there are two main methods available to
enchantment decks: generic enchantress effects,
and stax pieces. Both of these are fine, but they
do kind of clash with each other, particularly the
rule of law effects. Preventing players from
casting more than one spell per turn prevents
playing more than one enchantment per turn to
draw cards, unless some of those enchantments
have flash. We can try to make them have flash,
but there will still be a natural barrier to
overcome every game. I could dial in harder on
a strictly-enchantress gameplan, but that’d lose
a lot of the appeal of Enigmatic Incarnation—it
makes a lot of sense as a toolbox control card,
and if I’m building a generic enchantress deck
instead I don’t really feel like I’m building
around it. As a final option we could mostly give
up on the generic enchantment synergies stuff and
focus on pushing our funky stax gameplan to
its limits, but I think cards like Sythis and
Sanctum Weaver are kind of required to keep this
a mid-power deck, and the lower this deck’s power
level dips, the worse its identity starts to
feel as a staxy toolbox control deck. Rule of
law effects are pretty powerful stax effects, and
it doesn’t make sense to fight low-power gameplans
with high-power stax. This isn’t to say that
bracket 2 style games should have no interaction,
and in fact both of my bracket 2 decks have above
average counts of interaction cards, but the tools
being used should be a little lighter duty. So,
at the end of the day, I could come up with cool
play patterns around a cool card, interesting
branching gameplans for the deck to run down, but
those interesting gameplans didn’t flow together
in a way elegant enough to keep up in the sort of
commander game I wanted to keep up in. I could
do a lot of things, and end up in some powerful
situations, but at its core Enigmatic Incarnation
just wasn’t a card that could give the deck the
amount of smoothing it would need to feel good in
the average game, and that’s totally ignoring the
concept of an opponent melting it with a removal
spell immediately. So, I scrapped the deck.
With all three of these decks, there was something
about them that excited me enough to spend a lot
of time building them. I had some idea of the
possible challenges that the deck might face,
but it took me a little while to fully weigh
what I found cool about a deck versus what
about it didn’t seem all that workable. With
that in mind, there are a couple exercises I
like to go through now when I’m building decks to
avoid dedicating too much time to a faulty idea.
The first of these is to think about the basic
plan for a deck, and then to consider how likely
it is that that plan will actually come together,
versus how likely it is that the deck will do
something else. Ideally it’s pretty likely that
you’ll fulfill the specific vision you had in
mind, but if it’s something more niche like a
weird combo or a hidden commander it might be nice
to make sure that the deck is fun even outside of
that. The Enigmatic Incarnation deck is an example
of one that kind of works with the enchantment
in play, but really does not function smoothly
at all without it. By contrast, my Sharuum
Astral Slide deck needs the slide to hit its
full lategame potential, but it’s a reasonably
fun artifact deck even before that happens.
The other thing to consider is how your deck’s
game plan fits into the context of an actual game
with actual opponents. What sorts of decks will
your deck be playing against based on its power
level? What will their experience with your deck
look like? Will your deck be good for multiple
enjoyable games, or will its gameplan get stale
for you and/or your opponents fairly rapidly? This
will usually be the bane of Polymorph and other
cheesy strategies for me—they’ll clear the bar of
being cool in theory, but in practice they’re
often boring to play against more than once,
and without that freshness I simply don’t find
them interesting to play on my side of the table
either. This isn’t to say that I can never make
a cheese deck work—maybe a bunch of other factors
all line up to make a deck enjoyable for me—and
it’s also not to say that what I find fun is what
you should find fun. You might very well be able
to take one of the decks I’ve mentioned today,
tune it to your preferences, and then have
a blast with it, and that’s great. What’s
important is that you know what you enjoy and what
you don’t enjoy, and that you’re able to check in
with yourself about a deck before dedicating too
much time to it. Remove the blinders of a cool
idea and give your deck a good proper look, and
if it’s still looking just as shiny, go for it!
Thanks for watching, and thanks to Archidekt
for supporting the channel. A big part of what
makes it possible for me to start building so
many decks and not even delete the majority of
them is Archidekt’s folder system. The fact that I
can separate my current decks from my prospective
decks from all the other random things I do like
precon reviews lets me stay organized, even with
dozens and dozens of decks on my profile. A
link to all my decks is in the description if
you want to check those out, including the ones
I’ve mentioned today. You can also check out my
Tymna Kediss list I’ve been thinking about, a deck
that I’ve put on the backburner but haven’t yet
abandoned yet. I have a few decks like that, and
I talk about them in a bonus second part of this
video only available to patrons and YouTube
members. A preview of that begins right now!